Patrick wait I thought of something
funnier than 25 maybe hear it 25 last we
checked you lived in a pineapple under
the sea spongebob you probably the last
cartoon character we would ever expect
to see a doppelganger for after all your
yellow and rectangular but sometimes
strange things happen yes spongebob
we've even found your real life
look-alike and we have to say the
resemblance is pretty uncanny cartoons
aren't always realistic but every now
and then we find someone who looks like
a favorite character he's watching for
10 cartoon characters that were spotted
in real life Dora the Explorer you don't
need your special backpack or a magical
map to find Dora the Explorer Dora is a
beloved character from our preschool
days who doesn't love the girl who
taught us Spanish through adventures but
we never expected to see her in real
life since Bo toe was snapped on public
transit this little girl is just so cute
with her Dora haircut she is even
wearing a pink top like our favorite
Explorer do you think she has a purple
backpack Carl from up up is one of the
sweetest Pixar movies of all time we
love that grumpy carl learns how to be
happy again thanks to a little boy a
talking dog and an exotic bird he was
voiced by Ed Asner but there appears to
be someone who looks identical to Carl
the nose and the chin are exactly the
same he's got the same smile as Carl too
with those glasses it looks like Carl
jumped right off that screen and into
the real world
Alfredo from ratatouille who can forget
the awkward cook alfredo linguine he's
afraid of losing his job so he makes
friends with a rat named Remy who is a
gourmet chef but it looks like Alfredo
has a real-life counterpart take a look
at this guy he is the same curly hair
his nose looks almost identical he even
has a similarly shaped face it's hard to
believe how close the resemblance is we
wonder how he feels about rats Andy from
Toy Story 3 ok this next photo was deaf
we posed but we can totally see why in
Toy Story 3 Andy is headed off to
college he is a lot more grown-up than
he was in the first two movies it's ok
this guy realized he looks a lot like
teenage Andy
he has similar hair and eyes so he posed
just like Andy alongside Buzz and Woody
it could be a live-action version of Toy
Story 3 Shrek now we aren't saying that
ogre czar real we would be really
freaked out if we saw a green guy with a
Gert ears walking down the street take a
look at this historic photo of a
wrestler from the 1930s and 40s Maurice
Tillet was named the French angel he
looks a lot like Shrek the nose and eyes
are spot-on
it's actually possible that till it was
the inspiration for strikes design and
let's not forget the wrestling style
scene from the first track movie when he
takes down four quads champions the
frozen sisters
this next look-alike is a perfect mix
between both Elsa and honest look at
this woman she spotted an Elsa cutout
and posed with that signature smirk not
only are their faces similar but she's
also wearing the same color eyeshadow
and blush as Elsa but she is in a
platinum blonde that red hair makes her
look a lot like onna - maybe she's a
long-lost sister of the arendelle
royalty Russell from up we have not one
but two characters from Pixar's up in
this video it's not just Carl
we found the real-life Russell and it
looks like his family saw the
resemblance to they dressed him up just
like the Scout character he's even got
the sash full of badges and the yellow
hat we can't believe how adorable this
photo is we put this kid could also turn
a grumpy old man into a nice guy
Rapunzel the feisty princess with magic
hair is another fan favorite it's
probably impossible to find someone with
the same length of hair but we did find
someone who looks pretty similar actress
Amanda Seyfried from Mean Girls and
Mamma Mia resembles Rapunzel a lot
they're both blonde with some
our mouths and noses but we think it's
those huge green eyes that really seal
the deals and Amanda usually plays
characters with bubbly personalities
just like Rapunzel mallanna mallanna
quickly became one of the most popular
Disney Princesses and for good reason
she's a go-getter with a great storyline
and her songs are awesome
now Moana already looks a lot like the
actress who voiced her alii crevalle oh
but that's not the only celebrity who
resembles the Polynesian princess fans
have been quick to point out that the
singer and songwriter
Alessia Cara looks a lot like Moana and
we totally see it she has very similar
facial features and the same dark curly
hair spongebob squarepants spongebob
squarepants is a classic cartoon
character he's been around for a very
long time and is definitely the last
cartoon character we ever expected to
see in real life here we are
this person is wrapped in yellow foam we
can only see their legs we seriously
have so many questions
where's the rest of the person or is it
a short kid why are they wrapped in foam
are they okay they're just laying there
which cartoon character would you love
to meet in real life don't be shy let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
be sure to like this video and subscribe
to the things for more awesome content
we'll see you next time
[Music]